politisch kommen heute zu einem neuen
video mittel eingebildet wir spielen
heute gta iv kinder und wahrheiten das
spiel david steht also auf deutsch
übersetzt
genauso wie mein kanal latif unterbett
ich bin dieser typ hier mit einer hand
hier fordert den offen unsere nachbarn
gewinnt nämlich mit einer waffe
unterwegs
gta für kinder hier hört schon die molli
gesät verhält mit aufgestanden und ich
kann jetzt fragte bei der linken hat mir
alles mögliche nehme irgendwo durch die
gegend schmeißen und jetzt liegt mein
stuhl neben dem mülleimer und kann ja
nach draußen geht es beispielsweise
dafür steht das telefon weg das diw geht
aber einfach mal nach draußen denn wir
wären schon wir haben hier verschiedene
waffen rumliegen das ganze ist aber
wirklich gta für kinder bei der damen
und herren also ihr seht wir haben die
keine bösen menschen wir haben gute
nachbarn waffe in der hand aber das ist
glaube ich nur weil er gerade
tontaubenschießen warte hier ich habe
das spiel hier schon mal hoch geladen
bei der nase läuft
bring lassen habe hey ich bin krank als
bitte verzeiht mir noch gehört dass ich
bei 400.000 wieder gesund werde halt
dein maul luca da das ganze hier ergeht
der appell kinder entwürdigt sagen wir
jetzt erstmal hier soll baseballschläger
weil wir wollen ja nur baseball spielen
und begegnen kinder so fällt man auf
jeden fall keinen baum im zaun kann ich
auf jeden fall kaputt machen hat
herzlich bei mir einfach hier sonnenweg
rüber zu den nachbarn und stattet man
einen kleinen besucher nachbarn
ab
sie können auch sprinten und ich quatsch
jetzt einfach jeden typen hier an alle
kollegen
das war eine tolle unterhaltung gerade
die ich weiß nicht ob ich irgendwas
falsch gemacht habe aber irgendwie
schaut er akkorde komisch und die haut
jetzt auch irgendwie ab er kommt wieder
zurück und der dahinter vw schon die
ganze zeit kommt den dahin bock wird
einfach mal wenn ich von hinten an ihn
ran und dann einfach mit dem
politik eurofighter wollt ihr denn alle
rita vergeht ja für kinder auf erwartete
blut aber welt voll schräger allerdings
das gute an dem spiel auch nicht so
lange von dem apotheker fertig wäre
tatsächlich ein bisschen anders
vorgestellt
[Musik]
worauf es geht wieder von vorne los
fleißigen zuschauer erkennen vielleicht
wundert mich hier 90 habe ich habe
vorher immer auf diesem stuhl hierbei
der videos aufgenommen und gehört
vielleicht auch das hier alte wenn du
vom theater halle
das ist einfach nur provisorisch gewesen
dass ich gerade hier mein wohnzimmer sag
ich mal aufleben punkt zu kommen ich
werde bald auch gucken lichtschalter wow
der coolsten punkt zu kommen ich werde
bald da hinten im auto mitnehmen ich
bereite da gerade der typ vor das heißt
dinge kommen die wende und weiter und so
fort
seitdem ich umgezogen bin manchmal schon
aber das andere thema also bald wird der
fall weckt ein und gewährte den anderen
hintergrund haben
der wunsch da die ja anscheinend doch
nicht so kindertauglich ist bin ich
jetzt mal antreten
die akte und schauen ob ich damit
ich habe gerade den baum davon mit einem
schlag kaputt gemacht und jetzt kriegt
man eine schaukel aber da war ich da den
mülheimer hier zumindest irgendwie nicht
nehmen hier irgendwie das geht wohl auch
das geht wieder toll super luca klappe
ja dafür dass in dieses spiel du hast
mich gerade die ganzheit verfolgerfeld
du willst du okay jetzt kommen welche
probleme hat auf einmal dahin haben wir
in unserem hinter sah
b wollt ihr alle
das wasser stehe hinter der getec wette
ich würde der bäcker bin ich habe noch
einiges offen
[Musik]
the following prozess crashed the
airship event red lake city utah das ist
toll dass er das versucht zu verbreiten
aber es passiert bei blinde aufgabe bei
den damen und herren report klein vom
tiber
jetzt funktioniert nicht mehr wer die
fehlermeldung dass spielen ich weiß
durch cyber hochgeladen habe bewerb ich
muss aber ehrlich gesagt zu geben ich
wollte dieses video heute ähnlich wie
lange halten das heute mal keine mittel
anzeigen für euch das video geht nicht
über zehn minuten ließ apple mitgeteilt
habe weist die ganzen tag unterwegs
waren verschiedene baumärkten weil ich
will mich an der wand weg akustik ich
brauch noch andere sachen schreibtisch
habe ich mir schon geholt in stuhl der
folter endlich mal angekommen dass er
lange bei ist aber auch alles egal ich
würde einfach sagen ich wollte einfach
dieses spiel heute spielen eigentlich
wollte ich heute ein kurzer zeit ich
hoffe von euch vielleicht trotzdem mit
unterhalten wenn das gingen dann lasse
gerne bei der bewertung da hier findet
ihr die eingeleitet wenn ihr darauf
könnte meinen kanal abonnieren und ihr
findet hier ein weiteres video
eingeblendet was bestimmt auch cool
[Musik]